As the nation's first international TV
channel and a window on Vietnam, Vietnam
Today delivers timely, accurate, and
engaging information about Vietnam and
its people.
And actually, immediately after the
official launch, the channel attracted
strong interest from audiences at home
and abroad. Viewers have not only shown
strong support, but have also expressed
high expectations for what Vietnam today
will offer. Our correspondents report
from the United States and the Lao
People's Democratic Republic.
Accurate information, compelling and
insightful content, and creative
communication. Vietnam today broadcast
24/7, primarily in English. It provides
multilangual subtitles tailored to each
country and territory where the channel
is available. In the United States,
viewers can access Vietnam today through
multiple platforms.
Yeah, it's amazing to have a channel
like yours here in in New York because
Vietnam is an amazing country and um it
deserves way more awareness and and and
promotion.
I can introduce you to the fact that
Vietnam also has a channel like CNN,
like CNBC. Being able to be updated and
informed in a direct authentic way is a
point that is very convenient and makes
you proud.
uh it can be a very valuable tool to
attract uh new business uh as well as to
help you know businesses that are
already in Vietnam. Also to begin to
show how Vietnam is a place to do
business. I still think there's much
more growth potential uh in the US
Vietnam uh economic relationship.
In Laos, viewers can watch Vietnam today
via digital terrestrial television and
Unel's OTT application. one of the
country's leading telecom providers.
We view your channel as a reporter and
also as a an outsider audience. I feel a
strong sense of connections since you
present almost every anchor of Vietnam.
You can learn about Vietnamese culture.
The Lao people want to access authentic
and vivid information about Vietnam. I
also hope Vietnam today will highlight
and promote awareness of the historic
tradition of great friendship, special
solidarity, and comprehensive
cooperation between Vietnam and Laos.
These deep bonds between our people will
surely resonate widely among Lao
audiences and international community.
The positive feedbacks and expectations
from viewers confirm Vietnam today's
growing influence while underscoring its
long-term mission to promote Vietnam's
image, enhance international
understanding, and deepen friendship
with nations around the world.